donc le composteur il est làbas
qu'est-ce qu'on peut pas mettre dedans
une peau de banane ou d'orange ou alors
des pelures
[Musique]
d'oignon une question qui mérite
réflexion finalement on met toutes les
épuchures qu'on a fini et après on les
met
dans ce petit quiz s'inscrit dans le
cadre de la Semaine européenne de la
réduction des déchets auquel ce centre
de loisir cours a souhaité participer
tout au long de l'année on a déjà on a
un potager on a un potager on fait du
compost voilà naturel on a aussi des des
animaux à l'intérieur sein même du
centre de loisirs les animaux en
question les voici flocon et clafouti en
intérieur et Roger qui gambade dans la
cour on change sal les tire des fois et
et on met dans le
compost activités du centre de loisirs
sont particulièrement axé sur
l'environnement et le développement
durable question de sensibilité des
animateurs qui transmettent cette
intérêt aux enfants ici ces derniers
font leur propre confiture et s'occupent
du potager ce jour-là l'activité Ren
c'est le compost le convoi exceptionnel
dirige la brouette jusqu'à son but final
on la litière de RET dans dans le
composteur pour quoi faire pour pour
faire pour que ça fasse de l'engrais
qu'ensuite on peut on puisse les mettre
dans la dans les plantes reste plus qu'à
attendre 6 à 12 mois la durée moyenne du
compost